hi guys I'm so excited right now because
rose in my kitchen yes yes yes yes yes I
love this this is like I feel at home in
kitchens and I feel this is an amazing
kitchen lost in them and I feel like
like I'm not worthy to have you in my
kitchen right now the things that I have
destroyed in this kitchen at any kitchen
but if you guys have not seen Rose book
or heard of her YouTube channel which I
know you all have because you guys have
been requesting this video for so long
absolutely incredible Jen and I were
looking through it and we were just
beyond in shock there's a lot of
pictures yeah but they're all so perfect
like I like step by step okay we're
gonna be here for a while and you and
you may wanna do a cast okay guys we're
gonna be here for a while anyway it's
incredible so go check it out put all
the links in description but what we're
gonna do today it's a blind bag cake
decorating challenge I've got a bunch of
bags over there with a bunch of random
things and we've got our cakes we've got
four different types of cakes can I look
in the bed okay and then while the cakes
are cooking we're gonna pick out the
random things that we have to put on it
yeah skinny face cake and even in tree
roots place cake before you know this is
really funny because I have never made a
spice cake you know what I don't think
it's all the box and you just don't put
it to the bank pump maybe it's pumpkin
spice is it no genie
no cheating okay okay okay and it's a
good cake all right so you ever baked a
cake using a blender before no it's kind
of like a mix or maybe let's go with the
blender do I use this yeah just smell
like a pumpkin spice smells like
cardboard spice
so we also did a Starbucks challenge of
her camel the mole spot video ever and
guess what I'm like I was reading
through the comment he said that the
caramel macchiato that we screwed up we
may actually use vanilla flavoring
that's why I thought it was a vanilla
latte it tasted like a big bad tape so I
need what do you need more egg whites
maybe should i do egg whites throw the
whole eggs does it really matter
I can't believe using a blender this is
my ground this is so awesome I really
hope this works I'm really hopeful how
long do you mix the cake in a blender
until it looks like it's good answer
let's do it okay okay ready go now we're
gonna hit the button and we're gonna
roll
get those eggs in there break them up
eggy shoot everybody Frieza office I've
never written cake from a blender this
is so cool it's good it's good right hi
can go really is this good perfect I
think we don't know Marty Raney's one of
the first yes I thought this is my
birthday I like don't know which present
to open okay I mean you pick one and
these are very risque they do not have
clothes on and cover them up with icing
digging sheet on a farm
yeah Decker oh don't forget the piggy
he's kidding pull your hands handy
perfect and I've got the astronauts
whole set
we've got tool I got the beer look at
these guys they're gonna cut Barney with
the astronauts this is gonna be a very
busy cake
hey next-best busy cake in the world
maybe I got too much stuff you like the
chicken okay I will feature the chicken
just for you princess
take care this is also my thing I got
plastic Hershey's or these three blue
brown yellow
okay bring the middle yeah yeah just
right in the middle all the way down
then sick good okay here's your splice
Kerry what about spicy cake how's he
doing good a little more difficult we
have to ice the cakes with this okay
what have we got green
here we go here we go
mix it maybe mix it this is great
it's very concerned what do you think
you think it's good yeah it's good all
right yeah I mean what what what I want
to know is what do they actually use
spatulas this big for I don't know what
cake are you making that this actually
comes in very handy I mean and this is a
personal defense it's just like a huge
wedding cake expansion
okay next looks pretty good okay not bad
fill in the gaps we're gonna do sport
field that looks nice there's the sport
field okay this is the party area over
here it's a good idea to be a bar
I've got dancing ladies at my bar is
fantastic
mine's a little different but that's
okay well horse pace over here okay yeah
okay you heard the girls kick me this is
200 not fair I forgot about this lady I
mean mmm
where does she go she the real question
isn't it it is
let's build her a pedestal these are the
two teams the two teams guys in the red
this is the farm team and then this is
the astronaut party team yeah it looks
pretty good the color scheme really
worked the fans that's the tools I
forgot the tools it's okay how are we
doing I got it I got it
oops okay I love how I say oops but
probably nobody would know if I know
they're in the they're watching -
watching a show and saying I need to
team names and for the astronaut party
and one for the farm team oh no I forgot
I'm just starting to think about it
I forgot the Heinz Oh what you gonna do
with that
oh I understand these are edible too
right yeah I think there's just full
icing so they don't have flavor though
not as much flavor I don't know crack at
peace all right okay it's a very
colorful cake I don't know if somebody
would ever request this kind of cake for
their birthday well but it's made with a
lot of love and creativity so maybe they
would now they're going to for sure so
we should discuss the case do you go
first
here is big sports game going on you
know we got two different teams and
these are their fans so the fans for
this team are the astronauts and these
party ladies over here left the blue
team and then red team barnyard and this
cow let's let your chicken thank you oh
my gosh we like that time I catch her on
fire so we'll just like the chicken yeah
we'll just like the chicken and there we
go I mean we weren't very good the
hardware on the side really feel like
you've incorporated all of our candies
ah
this right here is a bar some light art
looks like a kiss my hope is your
flaming beer shot they are fireball our
ladies are serving up a nice drink for
the nice clientele which one is the farm
animals this is woody this is his
subwoofers and those are some lighting
and spider-man and a stormtrooper yeah
bb-8 is watching and the horses he's a
bodyguard for the girls perfect
oh this one's for you thank you let's
try yours first okay roll it sweet bro
eyes sweet I know oh cool oh sweet look
good hmm the cake actually bakes really
well just hand mixing it yeah okay what
is this
Oh real crunchy well it seems like a
little dinner special though it tastes
like gingerbread mm-hmm like gingerbread
cake actually like oh my god oh great
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this amazing whatever we just
did make sure you go check out roads
channel and be sure to check out our
Starbucks challenge because that was
such a fun yeah it was so much fun
be sure to check out her book because
it's not amazing thing ever
honestly I want to show you guys it
again because it was but there's a lot
of youtuber books out there this is what
you need to get see I don't sweet I'm
like getting embarrassed it's so good
when people say like you know they
literally can't even like I actually
know I can't wait I love this girl I
love you thing so much for making a hot
mess in my kitchen thanks for inviting
me over and making me helping me make
the most amazing birthday cake I could
ever imagine
thank you so much that's it we'll see
you guys later